what's going on guys this is rob and i
have a theory
[Laughter]
shang chi miss marvel
all that kind of stuff and i i feel like
it all points to the idea of captain
universe now i know that's gonna sound
crazy but bear with me here for a second
and i think the evidence actually leaned
towards this idea but only if you know
where to look because we know the mcu is
very big on drawing on like super
obscure things in order to put pieces
together for more familiar things so
let's talk about let's talk about the
the whole thing with like the quantum
realm let's talk about that for a second
so when it comes to the quantum realm
what is this in the marvel cinematic
universe in the mcu the quantum realm is
basically their version of the micro
verse from marvel comics why because
marvel can't use the microverse they
don't have the rights to it and so
basically the mcu had to create its own
thing but the quantum realm is by all
standards of measurement a stand-in
there are differences like the micro
verse for example in marvel comics is a
microscopic universe it has galaxies and
stars and planets and people citizens
the whole nine yards kingdoms and so on
and so forth but it is its own place in
the marvel cinematic universe we've seen
precious little of the quantum realm but
what we have seen indicates that like
there may be entire cultures and
civilizations and galaxies and stuff
that exist out there we don't know how
far reaching it is we don't know exactly
how deep the microverse goes i'm sorry
the quantum realm goes i'm sure we'll
find out as time goes on as far as i'm
aware i think it's still a theory the
tva existed in the microverse or the
quantum realm i'm not entirely sure if
that's the case honestly i haven't
really looked into it too much since
loki ended but the thing about this is
that these have
striking similarities one of the big
questions a lot of people find
themselves asking is how is it that
janet van dyne existing in the quantum
realm for as long as she did became as
powerful as she was and a lot of people
are just kind of like well that's just
the nature of the quantum realm right
it's just a source of immense power and
that's true to a degree but there is
potentially a little more to it than
that and that's the form of or at least
the object or the thing that we know as
the enigma force in marvel comics so
while it has kind of changed more
recently regarding like nola symbiote
god and that kind of stuff the enigma
force we don't really know its
definitive origin we don't know exactly
where it came from the earliest thing
that we know in terms of the history of
the enigma force came from uh marvel
preview number four in 1975 by bill
mantlow and ed hannigan and what we
ended up finding out is that at some
point in the distant future you had a
guy named prince wayfinder and that his
people were quite literally being hunted
down and killed by a group called the
world demons in an effort to escape
their own destruction they escaped that
future and traveled to the past about 65
million years before the modern day and
what prince wayfinder did is using the
enigma force which was channeled through
an object called the sword and the star
he basically created the microverse and
that allowed his people to essentially
hide away right to hide away inside this
tiny little itty bitty microscopic
universe and they just stayed there ever
since now in terms of where the enigma
force came from we're not entirely sure
marvel's never really explained it the
only real reference we have is that the
enigma force basically permeates and
exists as what's essentially holding the
microverse together but the enigma force
can bond itself to a person and that
person will become captain universe and
in doing so are basically a protector of
the universe itself when the enigma
force bonds to a person is just
arbitrary it's always only ever based on
a story different things like that so
the power they possess is relative to go
along with that so like if you go when
you read acts of vengeance spider-man
became captain universe he had the
enigma force the most incredible thing
we saw him do was like punch the
incredible hulk into the atmosphere and
like that was it right it wasn't
anything crazy it wasn't like he altered
reality on a universal scale but if you
go and you read the events of like
spider-verse for example you end up
learning there's an alternate reality
out there where peter never lost the
enigma force and he became godly in
terms of his powers so the enigma force
can do a lot it's just contextual based
on the story if you go and you read
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers for example oh my god i love
that story you go when you read that
story like you got captain universe in
that story and while the power that we
were shown or at least the power that
she was stated to have had was
astronomical she couldn't stop the
collapse of the multiverse so literally
her role in there was more ceremonial
than anything else but the thing about
this is that when it comes to the enigma
force itself you look at janet van dyne
she was really really powerful she was
wildly capable in terms of what it was
that she could do but the thing to also
bear in mind is we have to ask the
question how does this connect to like
shang chi and miss marvel and that kind
of thing well if in the comics the
enigma force could be channeled through
the sword in the star then what's to say
the enigma force can't be channeled
through the ten rings of shang chi
and the bracelet of miss marvel we know
they're incredibly old we know from the
post-credits scene of shang qi even
though it doesn't necessarily speak to
the bracelet of kamala khan we know that
like the the rings themselves from what
we were told are incredibly old right
just extremely we're not given a
particular time but we know they're at
least older than a few thousand years
because that's when the father of shane
chi got his hands on them right we also
know the rings themselves are
essentially sentient that in that
essence in the the post-credits scene we
learned that it wasn't until shang chi
got the rings that suddenly the beacon
started going off that's literally what
uh what wang says right as soon as you
put the rings on a beacon activated and
started sending a signal somewhere so
what this seems to indicate is only
certain people were able to use the
rings you're able to activate this
beacon by using the rings whether it was
anybody beside shang chi we don't know
right the circumstance just gave a shang
chi and that was basically it and so
what it does is it hits this idea that
the rings did not want to send that
beacon out until the right person was
using them at the same time you look at
kamala khan while this bracelet was
passed down from seemingly one
generation to the next it would explain
why there's never been any explanation
of this bracelet being used by anybody
except for her now we're only one
episode in there hasn't been a lot of
information given to us aside from the
fact that like the bracelet can do some
stuff so maybe that information will be
forthcoming later on but it's not
outside the realm of possibility that
those two things came from the quantum
realm we don't know where the beacon is
being sent there's nothing to indicate
that a beacon is being sent anywhere
into uh you know outside the universe
itself we're not giving an answer right
shane she's like where's the beacon
being being sent to right and ultimately
carol danvers takes off but we know from
like carol danvers and from bruce banner
and all of them there's nothing about
these those those rings that indicate
that they come from
anywhere recognizable they don't match
any form of alien technology that exists
in space they don't match any form of
technology that exists on earth they
don't match anything in the magical
codex as far as the sorcerer supreme is
aware they're literally just enigma
objects right they're enigmatic we know
nothing about them what better way to
have an object that channels the enigma
force than an object that is in itself
enigmatic now we may end up getting you
know an explanation later on down the
line but when you look at the bracelet
of kamala khan and you look at the ten
rings of chongqi they look almost
exactly alike in terms of how they
appear the material that they're made of
as well as the energy they emanate when
they're being used so the question here
is do they really come from the quantum
realm and if they do using just marvel
comic logic and looking at the sword and
the star there's no reason to believe
that these are objects that cannot
channel a person or chant allow a person
the ability to channel the enigma force
to literally channel it and use it now
the question has to be asked here if
that's the case then was it possible
multiple people were using them and i
think the answer to that question is no
i think at one point in time they belong
to one person now it's possible they
belong to multiple people in marvel
comics the enigma force at one point in
time did spread its power among multiple
people and then eventually stopped and
started you know basically channeling
its power into a singular person but
while this might sound crazy i want to
propose this idea here because it really
is kind of teased in the eternals movie
where you have the unimined right like
multiple people merging themselves into
a singular mind or using that mind to
achieve a variety of different effects
not outside that realm of possibility
when it comes to uh to the enigma force
in captain universe that happened in
micronauts number 35 back in 1981 where
basically the sword and the star was
destroyed but what happened is you got
had a guy named arcturus ran who was
merged with dr stephen strange and
turned into captain universe so it's
it's there's precedent to merge two
people or more into a singular entity
and that person becomes captain universe
so that's entirely possible here like
what you're looking at is the potential
build up to a situation where you have
basically shang chi and you've got
kamala khan and those guys all
channeling the power of the enigma force
in different ways or they would all be
merged into a singular being using the
enigma force and like the different
aspects of them would be used in
different ways right it's entirely
possible that like the rings are not
actually bracelets they're legitimately
rings and when captain universe
manifests maybe the rings shrink down
and just end up on his individual
fingers i mean it would look a little
weird to see a captain universe running
around looks like he's just balling out
right like literally just rings gold got
like a gold chain around its neck
but i don't think this is the last of
these artifacts that we're going to see
i think we're going to see more of these
artifacts right more of these things
kind of circulating around but i do
think there's room here to make a
credible argument that what kamala khan
is doing and what sheng chi is doing and
other people will most likely be doing
as well is basically channeling the
enigma force it's channeling this source
of energy from the quantum realm but not
knowing it the real way i think the real
time when we'll get this answer the
actual way we'll get this answer will
likely be an ant-man 3 quantum mania and
very at the very least if janet van dyne
lays her hands or lays her eyes on these
artifacts that are used by shang chi and
kamala khan is just being like i
recognize that that's from this that's
from the quantum realm you're channeling
the power of the enigma force i think
that's possible i think it's entirely
possible that that's what we're looking
at but again i don't know we won't know
for sure until some future explanation
is given this is really just a theory on
my part but let me know what you guys
think right do you guys think that we're
looking at a situation where in effect
they're channeling the enigma force and
at some future point in time due to some
massive conflict possibly the fight
against uh kane the conqueror that
they'll be merged in together into
what's basically captain universe in the
same way the eternals merge into the
unimined let me know what you guys think
i'm very curious about that but anyway
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
and i will catch you all later
peace